(cap clicking)
(water pouring)
(pounding music)
- [Narrator] If you had to
rank yourself against others
based on a specific trait,
what would it say about how you see them?
And how they see you?
To find out, we brought
together six people,
blindfolded them,
and had them rank each other
based on their perceived weight.
Then we rearranged them
based on their actual weight.
This is Ranking.
(pounding music)
(timer beeping)
- I have a sweet tooth, but
I love vegetables and fruit.
(contestants laugh)
- I'm actually vegetarian
but I also have a major sweet tooth.
- I also partake in the sweet tooth.
(contestants laugh)
- I feel, I guess, I mean,
I have a sweet tooth too.
(contestants laugh and chatter)
- Is anybody here on a strict diet?
- I was on the keto diet.
It was tough because, you know,
you limit yourself.
Specifically on carbs, right?
But once I saw like the numbers on a scale
I was like, okay, "This is kinda cool."
Yeah, I did it for two years and you know-
- [Steven] Hey, two years
is a long time to go keto.
- It's a long time.
My doctor is like, "You
should not do this."
- I tried to be vegetarian for two years,
but I'm anemic, so.
Yeah, so I get a little dizzy sometimes.
- I think any sort of restrictive diet,
I have like a past with
EDs and stuff like that.
So I just made,
I went from vegan to plant-based basically
to make it a less of a,
I don't know, toxic kind of feeling.
But I know people can do it
without it being an issue.
- I might be generalizing
here, especially in America,
I think there's a definitely
food addiction problem.
And I definitely have felt it in my life,
just overindulging a lot.
- I grew up in two different households.
So like my dad's side, he always cooked.
And then we had to eat more vegetables.
You go to my mom's side
and she works all day,
so she doesn't cook.
And I usually ended up getting McDonald's
or something over there.
- Like the convenience thing?
- [Sabrina] Mm hm.
- [Carmen] Yeah.
- I think food, when I was younger,
a lot of it can be seen
as a coping mechanism.
If you were someone who
might be experiencing
some kind of, you know, trauma,
or you know, even just elementary,
just being bullied and stuff like that.
It's just such an easy thing
to just find pleasure in.
- Like the comforting thing?
- Exactly. Super comforting.
- Also rewarding.
Like, if I had a good workday or
something like that, I'd be like,
"I deserve Starbucks."
And it's like, you can't
do that every time!
- But that's the hard
part about it, right?
You wanna reward with it.
You want to punish with it.
It's everywhere.
- I feel like since
I've become vegetarian,
it's definitely limited my
access to certain junk foods.
I think a big reason as
to why I became vegetarian
was to help manage my weight.
- My boyfriend is vegan
but I would never be able to be vegan.
And then he wants me to cook for him.
I'm like, oh Jesus.
- [Steven] What do I use?
- What's y'all's
relationship with activity?
Do you do it to look a certain way?
Or do you do it because you enjoy it?
- Because I'm anemic,
sometimes I feel so dizzy already.
And I know that if I work out
I'm just gonna feel a
crap the rest of the day.
But I do want abs, you
know what I'm saying?
I don't have the kind of discipline
that a lot of people do when
it comes to working out.
- If you view it as discipline though.
I feel like maybe viewing it
as a way of, I don't know,
like a fun activity versus
like I want abs kind of thing.
- Right.
- I think that that's spot on.
'Cause for years I've
been going to the gym
and then forcing myself to,
and I've absolutely hated it.
But over the last, I would say
since September of last year,
I'm at the gym seven days a
week, three to five hours a day.
- My particular thing is weightlifting.
Cardio is something I've
never been friends with.
- Rich, how often do you
say you go to the gym?
- Now? I would say
probably two to three days.
Just because my motivation
hasn't been on par.
- Would you say like,
were you portraying that
in your food as well?
Cause like I go to the gym a lot
but I'll go home and eat pasta.
Right?
- Oh, got you. No, I was...
- I was a swimmer for like
10 years and then I got jobs
and all that stuff and I
didn't work out for two years.
Then I got into pole dancing,
which I've been doing
for like two years now.
So I got like refit again, it feels like.
- As a mail carrier,
I would say that I'm
moving pretty much all day.
I usually hit the gym
and I'm there about five
or six times a week
and just my entire life
I've always played sports.
So I've always been pretty active.
(curious music)
- Based off of the fact that
I believe I might be taller than Sabrina,
I think she should move
to the right of me.
- [Carmen] Okay.
- I don't think I should be the
lightest is what I'm saying.
- No, I don't think so either.
I think, was it Laila?
- Yeah.
- I think you should-
- Yeah I think you need to move.
- All the way where Steve is.
- Why do you think I should be over there?
- 'Cause you're, aren't
you veg, vergetarian?
- Vergetarian? (laughs)
(contestants laughing)
I was gonna go based off of like,
basically you sound small,
but not in a bad way.
- Do you get cold?
- I get cold a lot.
- Okay, so you don't have
meat, probably, to warm you up.
(group laughing)
- Coming into it.
I knew that I was probably
gonna be on the far left side.
- I think her and Steven
should switch us up.
- Bye Steve.
- Bye Sabrina.
It's been good standing next to you.
- [Sabrina] I know.
- [Steven] Bye, Rich.
- Bye.
- [Ruben] Okay, so you're Steve
- Carmen. Aren't you vegetarian?
- [Carmen] Yeah.
- So I think we should switch.
- And you dance, right?
Oh yeah, you definitely, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Like hold hands and rotate out.
- All right, so I'm next to Sabrina now?
- Yes.
- Wait, who's next to me on my right?
- Rich.
- Rich. Oh, okay, you're still here.
- Still here.
- I think we should switch spots.
- I agree.
- I'm just going based
off of how tall he sounds.
- I would agree with that.
- [All] Yeah.
(contestants laughing)
- [Carmen] Who's the one between?
That's Steve. I think it's Steve.
- Yeah, you're all the
way to the left, pasta.
- Yeah. You know what?
Pasta boy stay down there.
- Steve does not need to be at the end.
- Based off of what?
- Based off of him working
out seven days a week.
- Oh, true.
- Okay.
- Rich said he goes to the
gym two to three times a week?
- [Sabrina] Yeah.
- Whereas Steve's
a little more active.
- At least they should switch.
- The pasta.
(Carmen laughs)
- Now, who's this?
- I'm still next to you.
- Oh!
- Yeah.
- I think we're good down there.
- [Men] Down where?
- Sorry!
(contestants laughing)
- Down which way?
- I think we're good
down to the smaller side.
- [Men] Okay.
- Regardless, you all
sound like seven feet tall.
Like I could not-
- Wait.
Where do you think you should be?
- Me?
- Sabrina.
Yeah.
- I don't know 'cause-
- Think you and Ruben should switch?
- I was gonna say me and Ruben.
I don't know Ruben.
- Let's do it.
- Think we look alike.
(contestants laughing)
- I would agree with the
Sabrina, Ruben switch.
- Yeah.
- Okay, we can do that.
- We're literally the same person.
- Now, who's this?
- Hey, Sabrina.
How's it going?
- So this is Steve.
- [Male Crew] Does anyone feel like
they're in the wrong spot right now?
- I still do.
I think at least Steve
and I should switch.
At least.
- I felt like she was wrong because,
again, just hearing her voice
and hearing her background,
I would've never considered
her being bigger.
So when she was moving herself,
I felt like she might've just been,
I don't wanna say not truthful,
but I felt like she was just,
she was talking down on herself.
- Can I say the program
that I'm doing, that?
- [Female Crew] Yeah.
- Okay. I'm in a weight loss program.
So I'm in a bariatric program,
in which I'm in the
line to do VSG surgery.
And that's where they cut
off 80% of your stomach
to allow you to lose weight.
I am in that program,
which is why I think I should switch.
- Can I say something really quick?
- [Richard] Sure.
- Sabrina. I did that program.
- What?
- Yes ma'am.
- Okay, so does that not tell guys?
(Sabrina and Steve laughing)
- Man, I want to take
off my mask and hug her.
Like, that was wild.
You hear someone going through that
and you know what it takes
to admit you need that.
And you know what it takes to say,
I'm doing it for health, you
know, screw everything else.
This is for my health.
I want to, I wanna move forward.
And yeah, when I heard
that, it was just like
my heart just started flipping.
That was weird.
Congrats on making that choice by the way.
- Yeah.
- I mean I just gotta say that's a huge-
- Did you actually have the surgery?
- Yes, ma'am.
- Exactly, so.
- Yes ma'am.
- If she feels very adamant
about switching positions,
I think she knows herself
better than we do, obviously.
- I think if you wanna
do it, you can do it.
- I think so.
- [Female Crew] Sabrina to your...
- Lil' do-si-do.
- [Male Crew] Who is happy with
the current order of the line?
- I think for the most part.
(scale beeping)
(anticipatory music)
- [Male Crew] 1, 2, 3.
- Oh!
- [Carmen] Oh my God!
It's so bright!
- [Sabrina] I can't even see!
- [Carmen] Hey.
- [Richard] Yo!
- What's goin' on?
(Ruben laughing)
- No one looks the way I thought they did.
(contestants laughing)
- Not at all.
- I thought Steven was like seven-five.
I'm not gonna lie.
- Dude, I thought you were taller than me.
(laughs)
- [Steven] I was like trying to-
- I was gonna say, I don't
think we got it wrong.
- [Male Crew] In spot
number six, we have Laila,
at 97 pounds.
- Oh wow!
- [Male Crew] In spot number
five, we have Carmen, at 138.
In spot number four,
we have Ruben, at 175.
In spot number three,
we have Steven, at 220.
In spot number two, we
have Sabrina, at 309.
And in spot number one,
we have Richard, at 315.
- We got it right.
- Yep, we did.
- [Announcer] You win!
- I never doubted you guys.
(contestants laughing)
- So, I guess I can reveal this now.
So I actually in the past four
years, I've lost 150 pounds.
- [Group] Oh wow!
- I actually used to be 441.
So I feel a lot better about myself.
And I focus on it every day.
- Mine is a big part of my life now,
'cause I want kids and stuff.
And you have to be healthy to do so.
In general, how I look,
like I went to Mexico
and even my friends were asking,
"Why aren't you posting any pictures?"
And I'm like,
"girl, cause they ugly!"
I didn't like how any of the
pictures were coming out.
So I literally came home from
Mexico and called the doctor
and was like,
"Can I on the program?"
So.
- You're not ugly.
Sorry to say that.
- [Richard] I was gonna
say like, nah, you, nah.
- [Steven] You're not ugly.
- Thanks guys.
- I don't know why you
wouldn't wanna post pictures.
You're beautiful.
I'm not saying like,
because you are trying to lose weight,
that inherently makes,
that shouldn't make you
dislike the pictures.
- [Group] Yeah.
- I think you're beautiful regardless,
but you can do exactly what
you wanna do with your body.
You know what I mean?
- Well yeah. I used to weigh 450 pounds.
- Oh wow.
- Yeah.
I've been big my whole life.
The food addiction thing was what got me.
And I spoke about that.
Very, very real.
Went sober three years ago.
Got the bariatric two and a half.
Quitting food was harder
than quitting alcohol.
And that shook me.
It's just as easy as
saying I snapped my leg,
I needed to be surgically fixed.
I was at a point where my mind
and my body were so broken,
I needed it to be fixed.
And I got that reset button.
And the misconception that I hate
is that it's the easy way out.
But they don't see the hard mental process
in what I'm going through now,
to fix the identity issues
I was working through
and all this stuff.
There's a lot of me
still broken from that.
I just wanna say to you,
I feel you were pushing
yourself down there.
Now that, and you too.
Now that I'm here, I realize I wasn't bad.
(beep)
I realized I wasn't that
bad when I was there.
You know?
So like, don't think you guys are
in the right (beep) right now, right?
Like this is the beautiful part.
And I think my view of body positivity is
pretty (beep) up.
- Because when I was
trying to lose weight,
I had everyone here in LA
saying, nah, you're beautiful.
Don't.
And I'm like, nah, I'm unhealthy.
Right?
Like I'm dying.
Like, you know, it's not about my beauty.
- [Richard] Right, right, right.
- Being the lightest one here,
I'm like anemic, borderline pre-diabetic.
I have a lot of issues just
because of my lifestyle.
But you know, I can't
necessarily carry the weight.
- Just cause I worked out a lot,
'cause I did a lot of sports,
I was always so thin.
And when I stopped, so people would like,
they always assumed I had like anorexia.
All this like different stuff.
And I was fine.
I was eating fine.
And then when they stopped
making the comments,
I thought that I had
like blown up basically.
And then I developed the body dysmorphia.
And then I was having eating disorders.
And when I lost weight doing that,
people would compliment me.
And that's where they
equate size to health.
And I was losing hair and
the least healthy I ever was.
But, since I was small,
they were like,
"Oh, like you're healthy."
- It's definitely important you guys.
Find yourself because as a big guy
I attributed my identity to my size.
- [Richard] Right.
- [Sabrina] Yeah.
- And now I'm stuck in therapy
trying to find out who I am.
Right.
Because I was Big Steve forever.
- My whole life I've been Big Rich,
you know what I'm saying?
And I have body dysmorphia.
Well, I still see the
dude that was 450 pounds
in the mirror.
People think that when you lose weight
the battle's over.
But there's a whole mental thing
that you're supposed to address as well.
And if you're struggling with weight,
whether you wanna get big or get small,
just understand there's
a mental aspect to it.
And you want to address that as well.
And at the end of the day
love yourself, you know, be healthy.
But there's more to it than
just the physical, I would say.
(calming music)